oh there's deer just deer
so speaking of deer my dad is it was
like obsessed with deer so he likes to
watch them so he created this I think
what to call it really like an infrared
camera that will detect motion so when
the deer walk past the camera it'll
transmit the video down to the house so
he can watch it and it records it on a
VHS tape so I'm going up to act like I'm
a deer and I'm gonna see if you can see
me down there now what's going on up
there well it's a motion sensor up there
that sets off the camera to infrared
camera camera Peter goes to transmitter
transmitter feeds down to the house here
is a receiver I recorded on a VCR tape
and I can also watch the deer live on TV
here dance another thing that's really
funny is this transmittance wirelessly
so I know anytime there is a deer
outside because the Wi-Fi in my parents
house quits working like dads are deer
out there cuz I can't check my email how
is my performance did I look like a deer
I'll try to get some food
the shoe pretty crafty with all these
camera making utilities and this is what
the inside of one of these looks like
you how'd you make all this yes infrared
LEDs on the front camera there's the
sensor and this is camo so you can't
even see it